[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
down
yes
[Music]
huh
oh
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
you can't stop the revolutions
this is what democracy looks like
show me what democracy looks like this
is what democracy is
[Music]
democracy
[Applause]
wow
usa
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
is
[Music]
pizza
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
is
[Music]
all right
oh
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Applause]
all right
keep your eyes open stay awake
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
we're gonna go forward
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[ __ ] up
oh
[Music]
i'm
[Applause]
all right we're going to take a quick
pause so you guys can get on the other
side of the barrier
[Applause]
make some noise
[Applause]
i'll see you there
[Music]
[Music]
oh
come to power
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
peace
[Music]
people to pass on
[Music]
is
this is what democracy looks like
this is what democracy
[Music]
[Music]
oh
oh
on the streets of chocolatey
naacp president thank you so much for
sticking with me
i just want to give a reminder to
everyone
we must remember this during this
election season
we must remember that we have a
president because
once someone takes that space we have to
keep them accountable
it is our responsibility as the people
because we are the people
we are
are the people we are the people we
are the people the people we are the
people
and we have the last thing you know we
have the future of
they have his agenda us we are what
empowers america
we are the people we must remember that
so we hold the power
and well the way that we can give it is
the same way that we can take it away
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Music]
[Music]
jesus
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
democracy
[Applause]
so let's pray for the nation let's go
jesus loves us god loves you
jesus said no greater love and god so
loved the world he gave his only son
that whoever
they don't love you like jesus christ
jesus christ
who loves us
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
up
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
oh
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you everybody for being here and
feeling in solidarity
coming from near and far yes
[Applause]
[Music]
black lives matter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
my
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yay
keep flying
[Applause]
key
[Music]
[Music]
two three
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
hit me
okay
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
get down
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
get up
i take a picture
how can you
take a miracle
here we go
[Music]
bring the droid
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
is
yo mikey
[Music]
[Music]
oh
so nice you know i've been thinking we
should call chucky on the phone right
now and ask him
what goes on
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
me
cause
[Music]
[Music]
in history
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
it is they stopped watching um so i
could stay here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
it's
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
i'm foreign
[Music]
hilarious
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you're fired
[Music]
every day every day
hey
[Music]
right
[Music]
jesus
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
hey
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
yes
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yes
good guys
um
is
yes
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
one two three
i get it
yes
me
[Music]
hello
uh
earlier today
is
we're talking about weeks not days
oh
numbers
distractions
thank you
yes
[Music]
y'all ready good afternoon
thank you for taking the time to be here
again today we are all working hard
to maintain a clear line of
communications with the media
the county election officials and our
voters
our office will continue to give
unprecedented
access the voters of georgia deserve
transparency georgia voters
deserve accurate real election results
election workers around the state are
working with
integrity to ensure every legal ballot
is counted
and no illegal ballots are counted
right now georgia remains too close to
call
out of the approximately five million
votes cast
we'll have a margin of a few thousand
the focus for our office and for the
county elections officials
for now remains on making sure
that every legal vote is counted
and recorded accurately as we are
closing
in on a final count we can begin to look
toward
our next steps with a margin that small
there will be likely a recount in
georgia
interest in our election obviously goes
far beyond
our borders the final tally in georgia
at this point has huge implications for
the entire country
the stakes are high and the emotions are
high on all sides
we will not let those debates distract
us from our work
we will get it right and we'll defend
the integrity
of our elections in some states there
are complaints about monitors not being
allowed to watch the count
in georgia this process is and will
remain open and transparent
to monitors if any member of the public
raises legitimate concerns we'll
investigate those
we are committed to doing anything and
everything
to maintaining trust in our electoral
process
here for every georgian regardless of
partisan
preference thank you
afternoon again i'm gabriel sterling
statewide voting system implementation
manager
you keep putting your microphones where
i put my computer um
essentially right now the outstanding
ballots
are about the same as they were this
morning not too much change on that
front
but what we do have is a little more
information on some of the provisionals
and the iwakapa ballots that are out
there right now
so let's see we will start with let's
start with the margin
right now we're looking at two million
four hundred and forty eight thousand
796
votes for president trump and 2 million
450
381 votes for vice president biden
and that gives us a margin
of 1585. that's where we stand right now
as of 308 pm on i guess friday friday
now
um we do know that today is the day for
the uh deadline for the military and
overseas ballots that would have been
postmarked
by tuesday election day to be accepted
and counted in the state
we do have some updated numbers on that
we'll see
on the overall side we have
18 0008 of those ballots have been
accepted
and it leaves eight thousand four
hundred and ten that are still
available to be received now again i
wanna re-emphasize this
that does not mean there's a bucket of
eight thousand four hundred and ten
votes ready to be counted
that means that there are 8410 votes
that could have been postmarked
on tuesday and could be received by the
elections official today
so as i said earlier it's going to be
more than zero
and less than eight eight thousand four
hundred and ten so it'll be somewhere in
that range we don't really know how
how many that is um i do have a county
by county breakdown of available ones
i'm going to
give you some of the highlights and
we're going to try to put this into a
release to give the details
following this press conference so
y'all usually want the big ones so we'll
go with that uh bib we're making it
86 are still out there uh
chatham where savannah is 395.
uh cherokee do you choose woodstock yeah
woodstock why 171.
uh clayton county 241 cobb county 569.
columbia county 247 coweta county 99
dekalb county 802 and i want to take a
note of personal privilege for a second
for the for the yankees in the room it's
the cab
not the cowboy not the cobb it's the cap
so
we got to pronounce these things doherty
another one of those where all benny is
they're 74. uh douglas county 111
fayette 149 forsyth 153
fulton 956. that's the single biggest
number i believe right there
uh gwinnett 741 um henry 238
this is another fun one it's not houston
in georgia it's houston
houston county 196. um
liberty county 173 there's a military
base there so there's a little
outweighed it to its actual size and
population
lowndes county where vadasta is 141.
muskogee county where columbus is 323
paulden county 105.
richmond where augusta is 244 from the
masters coming up soon
rockdale 88 is 80. and i think that's
all the biggest ones so you can take
those add them together and the ballast
will be probably about 4 000 for the
rest of the
159 counties that i didn't name so after
that we have the provisionals
and i do have the provisional an initial
provisional report from fulton county
which is obviously the largest one which
had the biggest potential impact
their total provisional ballots received
was 4 869.
they accepted 3603 so that means they
rejected 1266 of the provisional ballots
they had on hand
um the biggest chunks of those were the
eligibility was verified means the voter
brought their id in and that was 1205 of
those
and they voted out a precinct which
means they were inside the correct
county there were fulton county voters
but they were at the wrong precinct
that's 2398. now the unfortunate part
for some of those voters and some of
those candidates means that they voted
out a precinct
essentially they could only vote on the
things that were on the ballot that
affected
the areas that they shared with the
other precincts so things like president
senator those votes will count but state
house county commission those races
would not
that's the difference when you have the
vote out of county like that we don't
like seeing voting out of canada we try
to encourage people
to be told to go to their correct
polling location now the rejected ballot
justifications we saw
on this is out of county 673 you can
only vote
provisionally inside your own county not
registers these people were not
registered
voters 573 and non-citizens attempting
to vote was 13.
so that's the the initial uh provisional
report from fulton i expect that to
change somewhat i was talking to our
fulton county monitor earlier he said
there were some other changes moving on
that as well as
some of the absentees that were damaged
they were duping i don't have a final
number on that but somewhere south of
300
that they were cut when they were using
the openers and things like that they
had to redo
they're gonna be scanning those and
those will be added to tallies today
um let's see not that one
you know you start to get crazy looking
all these spreadsheets um
they are not they are not as i
understand they have not scanned and
uploaded those yet
justin justin you're getting ahead let
me get through all this you can come
back later
um all right so the total number of
provisionals in the state
um this is not the total number this is
we have the numbers from 134 of the 159
counties
and we have a lot of the large ones but
i don't think we have all the large ones
like we're still then we have the cab
okay clayton i think we might have all
the big ones in here now again
this is a moving target dealing with
elections workers who are doing lots of
things at one time we're very happy
we're working together
to get this information to the viewers
and the voters out there
um and guess what gabe didn't hit the
sum on all these things yet so we're
going to take a second while he does
that on live television because that's
the exciting television you all came for
today
all right
thirteen thousand and twelve is the
total number of provisionals we're
seeing right now
that includes the fulton county number
so you can back those out from what i
just gave you so it's really closer to
nine thousand
and they have these fun things called
codes
um and these are the different states
a provisional can be in it can be for
curing your voter id there's two
different versions of that there's a
general voter id like you forgot it was
a first time voter id
but then have a good voter id on file
then there's a provisional not
registered which they couldn't prove
your registration at the time
but you can come back and cure that um
extended hours
as you all may know we had a handful of
precincts around the state that were
extended past the seven o'clock hour
under law
all those votes are provisional until
until just in case a court adjudicates
that they shouldn't have been open but
they they will all get counted
um then you have out of precinct which i
was describing before where you could be
in the right county
but you're in the wrong precinct not a
citizen pretty self-explanatory and then
we have what we call incomplete
registrations where they have a partial
registration system but they don't have
enough information to identify the voter
they have the opportunity to come back
and cure those uh we will again try to
work on getting a breakdown of those out
to you all
but the biggest one is going to be the
emma let's see
out of precinct voters and that's going
to be column g so we'll see how many of
those there are
these are ones that will be counted and
ended up being included into the account
3908
and you don't have to take the subset of
the fulton out because they didn't
include that so
the 3908 is of the counties we have not
including the fulton ones with i gave
you those numbers earlier
um we are again we're seeing uploads
every 20 30 minutes as the counties go
through the final stages of trying to
get everything done today
with the yu acaba the absentee cures and
the um
provisionals being verified so you're
going to see lots of uploads what we've
noticed is
it goes up three on the margin goes up
three goes down two goes up seven i mean
so you're not
nothing is moving the needle a lot on
these things so we're still hanging
around that 1500 number right now
but the larger trunk of provisionals
could potentially move at some
the yuakov could potentially move it
some the duplications
of damaged ballots can move at some and
again it depends on where they're coming
from
and we're still trying to get everything
closed out today it could slide to
tomorrow and again
when you have a my entire high school i
think was about 2 000 people and we have
less than that involved in the margin
here so every one of these votes is
important
and the job of the elections officials
in this office is to assure that every
single
legal vote is counted and that the will
of the voters of state of georgia is met
on this very very important election now
justin you can ask your question
okay uh when we're looking at a timeline
here
we are not talking about knowing who won
this election
given the strong probability of a
recount
uh we will not be able to ascertain that
now we're going to go through our legal
processes which means we have to certify
and i do anticipate that there could
potentially be lawsuits from both the
biden campaign of the trump campaign
depending on where they are and what
they're looking at that a judge could
order the counties or the state to do
different specific things but right now
we're operating the laws of the state
that we currently have
the timeline we have we're trying to
move to the risk limiting audit as fast
as we can to county certification
and then following the risk coming audit
the certification of the state
and then likely whoever is second their
initial request for a recount
as i said earlier in a situation where
the
margin is you know so small you don't
need to have anything as rampant
you're there's irregularities that you
can see that's very very common in
nearly every election
but all in this particular case every
single one of them is very important
every insight we've gotten every report
we've gotten is going to be investigated
fully
and we are working hard to protect the
integrity of the vote regardless of who
makes a complaint about any of these
things
we can't say that sir yet because
they're still under investigation yes
sir
um it's a few hours ago
where are the mystic military georgia
what happened
well we still have a few hours to see
what will be coming in from the u.s post
office that has to be postmarked by
tuesday so we feel like that
we will have an answer to quote not
missing ballots their ballots are going
to make it there's ballots that are not
going to make it we're going to count
all the legal ballots
legal ballots have to be here i close
the business today and had to have been
postmarked by election day yes ma'am
well if you notice the difference of the
on the amounts that i said here today we
had about seventeen thousand
five hundred give or take yesterday
eighteen thousand days so 500 of them
have already come in in the last few
hours been processed by the counties
yes john
today tomorrow
again we report the results from every
county
at some point the legal process
continues that we have the council to
certify
once the county is certified we look at
their paperwork and make sure it is all
clean and legal and then we will certify
that is the point at which
the secretary of state would stand here
or stand wherever he might
and say this is the winner of this
election that stands right now and then
we of course we anticipate a recount
coming
and then prior to that
the process we have is what gets us to
that point we certify
that means these are all the legal votes
we have and all the legal votes are
counted
is the legal process been set up in the
state for many decades yes ma'am
it's the 13th for the counties and at
the outer end the 20th for the state our
intention and our hope and working
diligently with the counties
is that they will certify faster than
that so that we may begin the rla
process the risk will be audit process
so we can certify before then so we have
a little bit more time wiggle room
to deal with what we know will likely be
a recount john you had a lot
hold on ma'am you can go ma'am you can
go ahead
across the board even in the secretary
of state speech this morning that was
his linkage as well because afternoon
i think it's just for clarification
because by definition you count all
legal votes means you're not counting
illegal votes
yes ma'am
um they have their pr what they're doing
right now hit and verify all
the of those first they will likely be
scanned today
and they could even be part of some of
the uploads we have seen today i'm
giving you the latest information we
have
and i do not believe most of these have
been scanned yet because usually the
intent is
you don't want to go through scanning a
bunch of stuff and have to do like eight
more later on you can't it's easier
process wise
to do everything at one time than to do
it in bits and pieces we fight with the
smaller
mount yes sir hold on i know i'm getting
a risk with your question this
anyway but you're right unfortunately
with the way we as i pointed out to you
yesterday before it's all kind of
running together for me at this point uh
the rules
and the scb have outlined this and one
of the rules is for ease of use
to a degree and obviously uh he's
pointing out that in a risk limiting
audit
the point is you're trying to use the
smallest number of ballots available to
get you to a point of
confidence that the outcome has been
reached when it's
at this point i think it's point zero
three percent difference
he is correct it would essentially be a
recount which would be extremely
difficult on the counties to do
so i think that might answer the
question for you itself
yes ma'am
our hope would be today they could slip
into tomorrow
because again everybody's exhausted it's
friday there's a georgia game tomorrow
it's kind of a big one we've got to
focus on the really important things in
this state sometimes
in order to recover to be prepared for
dealing with what is now a vital thing
for this country yes ma'am
oh sorry yes ma'am
well i think what president trump is
trying to encourage is the hope that as
many of our military heroes men and
women across the seas
have turned in their battles and they
will be arriving under the legal
deadline of this state yes ma'am
as i understand that's pretty normal yes
yes sir
we'll come back to you in a second
irregularities can you tell us how many
you are investigating without going into
specifics
i really couldn't answer that because
frankly i just don't know i'll try to
figure out something for it we'll talk
to you with this guess now yeah
chief of investigations i need some
water hold on
um that's what i said that was probably
correct let's see
yeah 13 0012.
now this is all provisional ballots
accepted not accepted discard i mean
there's
you know that none of these have been
again latest numbers we have
none of this is either for sure gonna go
in except the number i gave you which
was the
out of precinct ones since everybody's
battle
has president on all of these will go
towards that and that is
3908 and again we're also missing about
20 counties out of this so that number
will be bigger at the end of the day
your follow-up
they're treated the same way yes sir are
you confident you're getting good
numbers
okay there's a difference on this
particular thing because you noticed
they pushed out results on election
night so what we're talking about there
is a difference between
what they've already uploaded okay and
then they had a
bucket of things that were the new ones
that came in tuesday essentially
and then there were some other ones that
were there from the earlier time they
had to rescan
so the 7 000 is what they were scanning
but the only new
votes that will be uploaded are in that
4 000 to 3 500 amount if that makes
sense
okay i'm going to try they pushed a
little over 80 000
votes in a single um upload and
there was an issue because of the
adjudication where they basically said
we're going to push out the results
and just the results we have right now
we're going to rescan these things
because at that point it was sort of
decided internally
there by their elections board that an
option and option b of how to do this
they wanted to give the information out
because that was the most important
thing at the time
so inside that 7 500 to scan
part of the results that we already see
are already there
so there's a new section stuff that was
the stuff that came in before 7 pm on
tuesday
and those are the additional ones on top
of that and again it was between 4 400
and 3500 and frankly
when i said 3500 i was talking to a
staffer and i thought i had a confirmed
number
and i it might have been wrong now so i
apologize for that but again this is a
moving target so that's about the reason
for the 4 400.
the answer to your other question yes we
are confident the numbers we're getting
from the county
is it possible they're off by one or two
or small percent yes because again
these people are underpaid and
overworked like so many right now
and they're doing their best to give us
the best numbers and we're doing our
best to be open and transparent about
where we stand
in the country right now i think we've
all come at this time
from every direction but just one last
time
at what point you anticipate that you
will be at the point
where you won't have to come out here
and say we have this many most
category
well here's the thing right now and it's
frustrating i know to people across the
country and i've been watching news
conferences from philadelphia and las
vegas and everything else
this is a legal process it's a legal
process we've been doing for several
years
and we are still inside the window for
ballots to be counted
following the different sets of laws
this is the outer edge of the yuakov
ballots being the last ones
of getting them legally established and
counted
this is the outer edge of getting those
provisionals validated
and counted we are now at the outer edge
getting the absentees cured and counted
so we will know the final universe of
numbers
by today and that's going to be an easy
thing to see now
after that we have to go through the
final process of you know
you're going to go through you're going
to kind of audit your internal results
you're going to make sure
that you know your numbered list of
voters matches the ballots matches your
cards i mean
there's a lot of processes that are
there to protect the integrity of the
vote that we have to go through
to finalize this that's why we have this
county certification process
now our intent is to try to move to the
state certification well the county
certification process first
as quickly as we can so we can move to
the risk limiting audit because that's
going to validate
as under our hb 316 election reform law
supported by secretary raffensberger and
passed in 2019 by the legislature
that is the thing that's going to let
people know the paper ballot that i
voted
and the outcomes that we saw were
correct that's a very important part of
this process
once that's done then we move the state
certification the outer edge of state
certification we have to do
is to be november 20th and why is that
i'll repeat it again
because we know we have a minimum of one
runoff and now looks like there may be
two runoffs for united states senate
and the iwakawa rules that are federal
on that require that we
get those um ballots ready to go
to the yuakawa voters and email them
they're prepared on
saturday november 21st so we have to
certify an election before we can give
out ballots for an election so that is
our outer edge that's what we have to
have done
yes ma'am
john's just being greedy today it's okay
that would be the intent because these
are unofficial results now remember the
official results whatever needs to be
based on
everybody's looking at it right now yes
biden's ahead by 585 votes
but that could change in the next few
days given the universal votes that are
out there he could extend his lead it
could stay the same
or president trump could come back and
delete there was still time and a
universal
ballots that could allow for that yes
ma'am
all right you're right on the first one
okay now on the second one um i already
gave you the full county breakout so we
know some of those are
so that 13 000 then drops to about 9
000. so then
inside even inside of that nine thousand
we know for certain
what will be added is three thousand
nine hundred and eight of the ones that
were out of precinct
so that then further drops your number
down to see nine thousand
we should never do math on national
television nine thousand four about five
thousand
okay so those are the potential
additional votes on top of the ones we
absolutely know will be input
does that follow up you get it good
thanks yes ma'am
the likelihood that some of them have
but i think the bulk of them will not
because like i said before process-wise
it's easier to do it all at the end of
the day
when you know you have everything
they're roughly the same right now we
haven't seen too much motion on those
and you're we've been seeing all day
long ticky tacky things from
all the little counties like three here
four there and that's what i was talking
about four of those things
yes sir
let's go through this one more time
because you're going to have a
certification process
where they're going to have to go
through and there's a lot of paperwork
and a lot of ability
to have to know that all of our ballots
from every single county
are there and accounted for and then
counted the county says basically
yes state we know this is our final
number we will look at it and assess it
and then we certify it but that's the
with the risk of limiting audit in
between and the risk living audit as we
know
is the item that's going to be part of
the foundation of bedrock of trust
because it's going to certify
that the scanners reflected what was on
the paper ballot votes for the first
time
so that's where the reassurance comes
from is the process following the law
putting in the risk from the audit and
then doing the certifications
yes
no sir thank you thank you very much
okay
what's up hey dude how are you
thanks for your uh